au moins de nom le groupe québécois mais
aucune bonne s'est imposé dans
l'industrie de la musique avec des
spectacles au québec en europe et
bientôt aux etats unis
lancé en mars dernier le premier album
let her morning a propulsé la carrière
de laurence la faune bond et camille
polique des fois on se le fait dire dans
vu leur arrivée pour moi les deux amis
de 23 et 24 ans ont joué avec de
nombreux artistes québécois avant de
former ce duo qui se démarque par son
style électro pop envoûtant la coupe
l'année d'expliquer le nom mais aucun
bon oui le choix du nom mais aucune
bombe qui signifie l'est et au sens
français s'est fait aussi intuitivement
que celui de chanter en anglais
et
ceci le planant s'est également imposé
naturellement aux deux musiciennes issus
du programme de jazz du cégep saint
laurent
je pense que notre relation en jazz nous
a aidé au niveau arrangements et au haut
niveau et apprendre à travailler fort je
pensais de la confiance aussi que ça
donne
en arrivant sur notre projet à nous on
est sans danger ni de vos jambes
notamment ce qu'on veut
de m pour montréal au festival de jazz
les invitations se multiplient cet été
elles ont même retenu l'attention d'un
réalisateur québécois pas de talent et
arts osheaga et il ya vu un spectacle
qui nous a appelés
une semaine après les faits jamais ce
que j'ai entendu saoulé par la trame
sonore de mon prochain film king dave
c'est vraiment une super aventure
après le québec toronto et new york
making bonne poursuivra sa tournée en
europe ici tanya lapointe à radio canada
montréal